no I agree you've got a point I agree I
I think like um women definitely do make
poor choices in men but um the quality
of men have kind of gone down
I don't think the quality of men has got
I really think it's the women but I
think so in in just regards to like you
said the father wasn't there this wasn't
there but I think sometimes people have
to take accountability like you said I
totally agree about taking poor choices
but once something has happened to part
of being a man is finding Solutions you
understand and rectifying certain things
so you see like like if you have a child
or something and it might not have been
the ideal situation but it's now your
responsibility to you know to be a good
father to your children do you
understand what I mean yeah so therefore
they're not going to grow up with as
much Daddy Issues not just leave them
well I think that's the women's fault
though like yeah because they picked
them like why are you sleeping with him
like why are you letting him like why
aren't you on birth control we have 41
forms of birth control pick one
and like why are you why are you letting
him back a guy that would be a bad dad
get you pregnant like that that's stupid
like what you can't change men and like
as women I think innately we know who's
gonna stick around we know who isn't so
why would you pick them and really and
truly it's a small percentage of guys
that are out here making baby making
machines bro it's a small percentage bro
it's the guys like the guys that
aesthetically look like Derek Jackson
Ralph do you get what I'm saying like
the guy that the the five foot five guy
is not the one that's causing all the
problems out here it's not bro it's a
six foot three six foot fire for like
Charming guy
you know what I'm saying that is causing
the problem so really and truly bro it
comes down to girls because initially
it's the woman who chooses do you know
what I'm saying and the women typically
leave too like like because the The
Narrative is that like men are the ones
leaving and we can't trust men because
they might leave but women leave more
than men do I was gonna say as well like
in I think because you work in divorce
court or a divorce yeah yes a major
major reason why I see that women are
you know men have pretty much stayed the
same in terms of very
not simple and derogative way but they
very basic stuff you know not have high
standards of what a woman should bring
but um
women have gone to universities got
degrees and you know all that stuff
in in recent years so that has been a
major factor in them thinking oh you
know what I could do better and that's
where hypergamy comes in
women have never had the skills like to
this level ever before and um where men
have kind of stayed the same you know
they're the they're the Breadwinners but
now when the woman can out earn him
naturally she'll be like oh I could do
better than him like what can he offer
me and that's really unfair because is
that his worth like just what he can
offer financially if the children are
eating the children are fed at like
babes closed so when she gets too
comfortable where you know what then she
starts thinking well I could just if I
can out earn him like what do I need him
for
um whether that's good or bad is
something else but then she has that
mentality because
yeah I think that's the main reason why
women you can see the change that women
have made and men have stayed the same
you got you've got chicks that are doing
only fans yeah selling their body online
making a lot of money because of Sims
again and then obviously even they will
have higher expectations because they oh
I'm making 10 racks a month so uh you
know I need to be with a guy that makes
x amount bruh like it just kind of
messes up the whole game like women are
looking down on nine to five yeah
oh my God can't win I've done so many
reaction videos to women saying ah nah
if a guy does 95 he they would rather
they'd actually rather date a criminal a
scammer yes then date a guy that does
nine to five because oh if I just want
to go to Italy at the drop of a hat he
can't do that he has to ask his boss and
yeah I need a guy that's an entrepreneur
or a scammer bro this is unrealistic
I've seen too many videos like that yeah
in the UK and the USA this is normal
stuff do you think guys like Derek
Jackson know what they're doing
absolutely yeah yeah
I'm sorry they're they're Jackson is
hitting a target audience and the
majority of them are black women and he
knows that if I can get them I have them
hooked and it's sad to say but they're
going to
keep going because I'm not sure if this
stat is correct but I think that the
highest like unmarried demographic is
um one of the highest I'll say one of
the highest is black woman and he knows
that if I
what he's saying is it feeding into
everything that is
them essentially
um
and it's it's hard to say because I am a
black woman and I I remember when I
first saw him and I was like oh yeah
like what he's saying is true like that
makes perfect sense and then I really
started listening to him and I was and
then all that stuff happened like I said
earlier and I was like wait let me
actually listen and I had friends who we
would talk about things that he said and
sit down and be like oh did you see his
video today and just discuss it and it's
very
is very disheartening when people hear
something but don't actually like listen
and like think about it but they just
take it and they run with it well and I
think a lot of stuff like simply guys
kind of say it sounds nice and it works
well in theory like raise your standards
but it only works well like if you have
anything to offer a guy
and most modern women don't like how
many modern women have cookbooks how
many modern women are virgins
beans on toast not the fruit beans
which is like it doesn't mean you're a
bad person or anything but it's just
like
um you know it's like you're asking for
BMW prices when you're a used Honda
Civic how many buyers you gonna get and
if you do get a buyer you know damn well
you scam the man and all these girls and
and then them particular girls you're
talking about if you ask them would you
rate yourself out of 10 I'm a 10.
yeah yeah you guys are tense yeah yeah
you literally have to I oh my God I
would kill to get that man on the show
after this no I think it'd be funny like
I don't know I feel like you can make
some funny content no it'd be good
though
I would ask him I'd be like why are you
simple and like what are you doing here
I don't think he'd come on I don't know
I just have a feeling the heat will be
too much
um do the next clip blessing
is there anyone you can think of who's a
bigger simp than Derek Jackson
this next person or the one we're about
to watch later oh you think he's bigger
no I don't
I mean
there's more sense out there trust me
once you see it you cannot see it I'm
about to ruin so many dating guys
that
you losing
and that applies here secondly I get it
it's like well she's taking everything I
invested into him no she ain't she about
to take everything he was using to
stress you out while blaming it on you
she just don't know it yet and it seems
like he's able to give her you know all
of these different fruits of of your
labor you know all of this good
treatment this money whatever he was
only able to do that because he was
giving you the rest of him he was giving
her the best while giving you the rest
now that she's in your spot he about to
give her the rest he's about to give her
all of that depression he was projecting
onto you because he don't need no
therapist that's what she about to get
that's all she's taken from you she's
taking his criticism whenever his money
get low she's about to take on all of
that neglect those excuses how little
that he was willing to help you around
the house and but whenever he took out
the trash once a week he wanted to be
treated like a cane That's what she
about to get she again she just don't
know it yet everything that he was
blaming on you she about to realize you
were not the problem and on top of that
she's no longer the new toy and he still
needs that spot filled now that she's
taking on yours he still needs that spot
Phil because we're not talking about a
guy that made his mistakes he did his
wrong but you know he wants to make it
right he's repenting no we're talking
about a guy that stepped out moved out
and he don't see nothing wrong with it
man what that girl took from you was a
blessing to you you need to be thanking
her and somebody need to be praying for
her because she next
oh
I have a feeling that he is he talking
to anybody is this like from like a show
or anything I don't know Michael you got
it I don't know what he's saying I don't
know he always like sitting in his room
acting like he's talking to somebody but
he's not talking anymore but it's not
the corner of the room yeah it's the it
again I was like is this you are you
just exposing Yourself by saying all
this stuff it I want to know what what
people he knows because I've
it's just like mind-blowing at the stuff
he's saying because it doesn't it
doesn't seem realistic the things that
he's saying I'm like the people that you
know really act like this and are really
doing these things or are or was this
just your story and you're just
portraying as it's somebody that you
know now imagine being his wife like
hearing him
you know it just sounds like she's like
you don't help her on the house that was
you you took the trash out once and you
wanted to be treated like a king the
rest of you you were streaming
depression on me it was you I by his own
logic his wife should have left him by
his own logic she did yeah but I mean
indefinitely Yeah by his logic divorced
like so he's just saying anything again
you know do as I say not as I do
crap I think he's just playing he just
knows what sells he knows he can just
drum up the audience he can get his
subscribers it's very common it's really
Shadow he's doing what he's preaching
himself so and he says a lot in in the
video it's not it's not really a quick
video he's saying a lot of things so all
it is is women feel good women feel good
it's not your fault it's the man's fault
yeah bro like it's it's a trick has he
ever done a video like opposite where
he's like trying to balance out you know
the field and I don't know
all the I've seen is
Sam I have not seen it's really like
offensive to men like even the therapy
and all that stuff like that's a
sensitive topic that's why no one don't
like him yeah
you never hear those guys say yes Derek
come on his wife's in the background
probably saying I told you to get
therapy you narcissist
yo she should come out with her own
channel
Jackson's wife tells off
she could just give dating advice and
not say his name how to spot a
narcissist yeah come on I knew somebody
that went through this aka me
if you're ever in this situation I mean
he made money off of her
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible